if you have exhausted rocket leagues
tutorials here are four more tips to
further perfect your skills in the arena
don't rush the ball be patient everyone
forming the ball at once will heighten
the chances of the ball launching in
random directions when there's heavy
action going on hold back and wait for
the ball to set up and center to you
this gives you the chance to hit goals
more precisely
always strive for 100% rocket booster
make sure your rocket boost is stopped
when the match starts or resets this is
the first thing you should do run over
boost pads and make sure there's always
gas in that ass
max boost pads are in the field corners
and mid field sides but remember your
boost is your last resort maybe used to
book it downfield to defend your goal or
maybe to launch up for an aerial shot
disengage the ball cam to more easily
pinpoint boost pads double jump to boost
again your boost is your last resort
when you're in need of speed double jump
to gain a slight boost double jumping
three times equates to reaching
supersonic with the boost combining
double jump and a small amount of boost
is the fastest way to accelerate to top
speed regardless you should keep the
habit of always double jumping for extra
speed both forwards and backwards
don't neglect your defense to simply put
don't be a ball hawk when you're in a 3
B 3 or 4 B 4 match
someone needs to hold back and lay down
the D this doesn't mean a defensive
player needs to keep inside the goal but
rather hang around center field and back
it's basic defense chuck that downfield
just remember someone needs to do it and
there you have it for quick tips to live
block don't forget to utilize the rocket
league training modes to tighten up your
shots and hey if you have any tips of
your own feel free to put them in the
comment section below
now get out there and do some damage
you